this phone belonged to a kid who went
missing down here 15 years ago
oh
here's what i know it belonged to sam
lawford who was this 22 year old college
kid from san diego and on december 24th
2007 him and his mom and his dad and his
girlfriend went to this resort called
the oceana vista now on christmas night
right the following night sam goes to
bed everything's normal everything's
fine the morning after december 26 2007
he's gone
he completely disappeared gone no no no
nothing gone gone gone now later that
day this other guest from the resort
violet thompson was also reported
missing but they didn't know each other
and there wasn't a single piece of
evidence connecting them
are you still with me
uh
yeah good because before the police get
a chance to investigate these
disappearances on december 27 2007 this
once in a century hurricane comes along
and destroys the resort
after they were reported missing now
here's where things start getting really
[ __ ] crazy because after the
hurricane this naked dead guy washes up
on the shore but his body is so badly
mutilated his corpse is like
unidentifiable they can't figure out who
it is they can't even determine what it
is that killed it but it's definitely
not sam and clearly not violent
two separate missing kids
and a dead body
and a rogue hurricane that wipes out all
the evidence
there's no explanation
it's dead end after dead end after dead
end
until this
until now
[Music]
what are you planning to do with all
this
i'm going to figure it out
i want to get answers i'm going to bring
some closure what if there are no
answers
well there have to be
because otherwise what is the [ __ ]
point what what is the po what are you
okay hang on what do you mean what is
the point
don't you miss it
guess what
i'm starting to forget things
[Music]
who i am
who we are
[Music]
i don't know i think i'm just tired
[Music]
no no wait wait
no hang on hang on hang on um
okay look um
what we should do is
just by turning these into the police
okay right but but
what is the difference between turning
it in now
versus
turning it in right before we leave at
the end of the week yeah it doesn't make
a difference all right so why don't we
just see where this leads us
don't get your hopes too high because
there's not you know there's a couple of
photos and there's some texts nothing
substantial yet
there's nothing substantial yet i like
that positive attitude that's going to
help us
this is driving me crazy
[Music]
[Music]
you